when I found out about the state I was
like that's brilliant yeah and community
property states that was really scary
like California is that's that's the one
where I heard this guy was like going to
retire and then he couldn't retire
because he his wife left him and took
the kid to Japan
yeah and like it it's crazy because I
guess in some states like the courts are
separate like the courts for like child
support and the divorce courts so when
he went to child support like to get
child support they would just say oh you
weren't in the kid's life the last six
months but they don't put in the fact
that like she wasn't letting him be
yeah so it's kind of it's very
um especially in the US here I looked up
I I think they get like 13 to like 20
ish per kid if that was correct right is
that yeah I don't know if that's it's
not as Cutthroat I think as the U.S from
what I learned but that's generally but
again they look at each and every case
which is important